what music are Terry's our frequency a
certain frequency that can be used to
insert messages that live longer than
let's say speeches came out here in the
very beginning one of our DJ brother
hard XD x DJ Charlie hustle as a family
friend of Mike Brown's family you know I
yola support the family the sound system
over here to be able to have the energy
of the young people to be able to
contribute today turnout because at the
end of the day those donkeys about when
I'm here for 64 days every day since the
murder of my brow of our leaders that
are bravest young we've seen right she
she I think music is ultimately I keep
organizing tool I found it in the hand
revolutionaries and people are ready to
speak that way one more download the aj+
mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store now